[MUSIC PLAYING]
BALA KASIVISWANATHAN:
Hi, good evening.
My name is Bala.
And first of all, sorry
for running 30 minutes
late on all our sessions.
Thanks for being
patient with us.
And we'll try to do our best
to keep this interesting
because I know that there is a
nice cocktail reception waiting
for all of you there.
So Prithpal and I, we're
going to kind of walk you
through some of the
product functionality
and capability, which
is going to be really
interesting for
you when you think
about the scale of
the APIs you need
to deliver for your companies.
So let's start with the
fundamental premise which
got us started thinking
about these things.
So today what happens in a
lot of enterprises we talk to,
there is this constant
tension between what
they are trying to do with APIs
and how fast they're trying
to move with the developers.
And at the same
time, they have still
some regulatory and
compliance burdens on them.
And they're not
really compliance
and regulatory
burdens, they just
have overall security
concerns, and they
need to kind of manage that.
So there's a constant tussle
between how can we move fast
and how do APIs help us get
there, versus how do we really
make sure that we have the
right checks and balances
so that we don't do
something for which we then
regret exposing all
these things via APIs,
or having a great partner
program, or other things.
So today our goal
in this session
is going to be giving you
some tools, some guidance,
and thinking about this in a way
which is compatible with what
you're trying to do,
which is to really open up
the APIs for your
internal developers
or external developers,
go as fast as you can,
and get the agility you
need within the organization
without having to compromise
some of the security concerns
that you might have.
I kind of alluded to this in the
previous session I was doing,
which is the one thing
we do want to reinvent
and re-imagine is how we
think about governance.
And the reason we
want to do that is,
in this kind of digital age, you
don't want an old methodology
for governance.
You want something that
helps you keep things secure.
You should be able
to get alerted
on things which you deem to be
insecure, but at the same time,
you want to make sure that
the developer has the highest
productivity possible,
because I'm sure most of you
have awesome
developers, and they
are trying to do
their best work,
and you don't want
to get in their way.
And part of that is why
you have an API program,
because you want them to
be self-serving these APIs,
using these APIs, and building
something interesting for you
and the business.
So when we think
about that, we go back
to the basics of the
foundational element of how we
think about the product itself.
And sorry if it's
a repeat for folks
who have seen this before, but
it all starts, in our mind,
with the digital value chain,
so where we really focus on what
are we delivering for the
developers in two phases.
One, it's an API
for the developer
who's building an application.
Or on the other side,
it's the developer
or the development team
that is producing the APIs.
And we've got to make sure
that those two constituents are
really, really happy
with the end result.
So what we have here
in this value chain
is to really make sure that the
balance is between those two
teams, or those
two constituents,
but more importantly, the
contract between those two
is just via an API.
And the reason I use the
word contract, again,
is that it has to be very
clear to the developer, who's
consuming the API,
what they're getting,
and how the API will
behave when they're
building the application.
And if we can't
maintain that contract,
then you lose the
trust and you also
create a ton of issues for that
application and the end user
who is eventually going
to use the application.
So in this case, for us, the
security and how you implement
the security is part
of the contract.
So if you don't think about
that as part of the contract,
what you can't do
is deliver an API
and suddenly go and change
it because you suddenly
have a new security
implementation or a need
and decided to change the
experience for the developer,
and ultimately, it
impacts the end user
who is using the application.
So when you are
building this API
and when you're
publishing this API,
you have to think about
security as part of the contract
and what else you think
is part of the contract.
For the API producing
team, I think
this is, again, in
terms of making sure
that while you create the API
which is very easy to use,
you have the right tooling built
in so that you can monitor,
you can analyze, and you
can do the right things
without affecting the developer
or surprising the developer.
So that's kind of the
other aspect of how
we want to think about this.
Now, as you're
building applications,
what your really end goal
is to really make sure
that we're building awesome
experiences for the customers.
You want to make sure
that the developer is
able to build the applications
faster and integrate faster.
The developer
who's using the API
needs to be onboarded
in an easy fashion.
So when you think
about onboarding,
it is also about making
sure that onboarding
happens in a secure way.
So for example, in
the developer portal,
you could say, come and
test and play with this API,
and you don't need
a key, but you
are going to be
rate limited, you're
going to have a sandbox
environment with mock data,
so you go at it, no problem.
But when it comes to
actual production APIs,
then you may want to
do things differently.
And you may implement a
set of different policies
which are to protect
your backend,
make sure that the
application does
a great experience
for the customer,
and it's very performant.
The API itself is a gateway to
your backend system so it does
need protection.
And while you're
doing that, you also
want to make sure that
there's a consistent way
to protect the APIs so
that each developer who's
producing the API
from the API team
is not figuring
it out themselves.
So part of today's
session is going
to be how do we let you
have a consistent way
to reuse some of these
kind of security policies?
And that's what
we're going to do.
On the other side, you
do want the automation
available to your API
teams to, again, use
our APIs for the
product itself to do
what you need to do in terms of
building new versions of APIs,
or releasing new
versions of APIs,
or implementing security
policies on the APIs--
again, at scale.
And the goal here is
not to do it one-by-one.
If you have a large
set of APIs, we
should give you the
automation to do that.
And then, of course,
your backend systems
are, again, I'm sure,
protected by themselves,
but this is one more layer of
security that we can offer you.
Now, as we think through all
the security implications
and reusability today, one
of the things we want to do
is really think about it
from a holistic API lifecycle
perspective.
So we talk about this a
lot with our customers
because it's not about
just exposing the API
or consuming the API.
It is really thinking
about this in a much more
holistic fashion.
And it all starts with
the API design itself.
So as some of you might
have heard from Marsha
in the previous session,
we are a big supporter
and we're part of the
OpenAPI Spec community.
And we really want to
contribute to making sure
that's the best open standard
for designing and creating
APIs.
So it starts with
the design aspect.
And we allow you to then
do interesting things
in our product to create the
right kind of API endpoints,
and then make sure that there's
enough security around it,
and then publish it.
So at this point,
what you've done
is you've taken a
very well-designed API
and then constructed
the right security
policies and the
right experience,
and then publishing it out.
And what does
publishing it out mean?
Publishing means it'll go to the
developer portal or someplace
where the consumers
of these APIs
can come and read,
and engage with you,
and consume those APIs.
Now, while they do that,
there's other aspects
of things which you need to
start thinking about, which
is that, how do I scale the
experience for those APIs?
Sometimes this could be things
like you have a store location
API.
And we've seen this in terms
of store location, content,
and things like that,
where our product is
able to actually cache and
respond to the API requests
faster without you
having to go re-platform
or re-architect what you have
in the backend and scale that.
So there are certain use cases
we won't be able to cache,
but most of the times, we are
able to do that kind of work,
allowing you to scale the API
consumption without having
to go and touch an
old legacy system
and try to scale that
at this point in time.
Or look at monitoring
these APIs usage,
and then decide what do you
want to do in terms of behavior
change, or performance
change, or even
think about systems which
are not being used up much,
and then make the right
decisions for that.
That comes with the
monitoring aspect
and with the analytic aspect.
So monitoring also gives you
things like is my API up?
Is there any latency
that's increasing suddenly?
How do I think about that?
And go and solve for that.
Last, but not the
least, in some cases,
you may want to go
and monetize the APIs
because it's the right way
to build an extra channel
or distribution model.
And when you do that, you're
trying and creating a new way
to open up your services to a
different set of customers who
are not engaging
with you previously,
or you're engaging with a
set of customers who actually
are doing it today, but
probably not in the most
efficient fashion.
So we have customers
today, for example, they
go on a one-on-one integration
with certain partners.
And it is almost
hand-coded, very
specific integrations that
take months to deliver.
And anytime you change
something on your side
in terms of the API, they go
and do that all over again.
The idea is to keep the
business relationship as such,
but try and improve the speed
at which you can innovate
and improve the experience
for that partner
and their customers
for the services
they offer from your side.
So this whole lifecycle
is extremely important
when it comes to thinking about
the security and the policies
and reusability because it's
not a one-time exercise.
So you want to think
about this at every stage.
And part of our
session today is going
to be thinking through
some of these aspects
and walking through
a real example.
So let's look at the three
things we will cover today.
And again, we are
not going to go
through each one
of these examples,
but I wanted to kind
of lay it out for you
so that you at least can
have a sense in terms
of what we are trying to do
when we talk about reusability
and consistency.
We talked a lot about security.
And we do have a ton of
features and benefits for you
in the product for security,
starting with API Keys, OAuth.
We just announced SAML
integration for authentication.
We'll have Role-Based
Access Control
for a lot of things
in our product.
We have a set of very specific
policies for threat prediction.
And then we also have
something for bot detection
and prevention.
All these security features
are available to you.
And you can decide
how you want to apply
them, depending on
the use cases you have
and when you want to do it
for a certain API, APIs,
and who the consumers are.
The second thing is
about visibility,
because people, once
they start using APIs,
as an API, what
you want to do is
look at who is using my APIs,
how often they're using it,
what are the typical
patterns of usage,
is there something else I
should be doing in the API
to make life easier
for those customers.
That's something you want to do.
But along with
that, you are also
doing something operationally,
looking at things like--
things are going not
well, looking at the logs.
You're looking at
analytics and looking
at things like, where are
the calls originating from?
Do I have the right kind of--
what are the distribution
between the clients?
Is it iOS or Android?
All those kinds of
things you can actually
infer from the analytics itself.
And last but not the
least, which is, again,
important from a
security point of view
sometimes and the compliances,
who had the access
and what changes happened.
That kind of auditing capability
is, again, available to you
in the product.
All these things give you
the right level of visibility
and the right level of controls
for what you want to do.
Then comes the reusability
and enforcement.
And this is something, again, we
introduced as a product feature
about 30 to 45 days back.
And the goal here is
to really give you
a set of tools to take
all the stuff we already
have in terms of
policies and the code
capability we have
in the product,
but package them as reusable
things for your developers.
Why is this important?
A lot of your developers
are just too busy.
They're doing things and they
don't have the time or patience
to learn one more tool.
So the more you make it easy
for them to consume something
from Apigee, it becomes
easier in their work flow,
and they can go and do it.
Number two, consistency.
And the reason you
want to be consistent
about this is, primarily,
the developer experience
was consuming the API.
It doesn't think that
you have 10 developer
teams within your
organization and each one
is producing something which
is very different in terms
of an API experience.
And they look at it and
go, you're one company,
how come you're delivering
these APIs as if you're
10 different companies?
That's the other challenge.
The last one is enforcement.
In certain cases,
sheer security needs
are that you want
to enforce something
and you don't want
to give a choice.
And that could be because
you have sensitive data,
you could have sensitive
business needs.
And there, it's not a
choice for the developer,
it just gets enforced.
Again, it still adds to the
consistency, but in this case,
it's more of a need for you
from a business point of view,
that you want this
to be enforced.
So when you think about
it in those three aspects,
the reusability and enforcement
becomes very, very important.
But going back to my starting
premise, which is you
do this with the developer
productivity in mind.
This cannot be a blocker.
This cannot slow the way
you roll things out in terms
of your APIs.
Or it cannot create a friction
when it comes to somebody
consuming your APIs.
So you really are looking at
delivering this reusability
and enforcement
in a fashion which
really does little to slow
things down from your side.
Now, you've heard
me repeatedly talk
about speed, reusability speed,
development, and productivity.
Why is this important?
The classic example today
is that when somebody
needs an API--
let's say somebody
wants to take in a payment API.
A developer wants to take
a payment API, use it
in their application.
The starting point is they
just do a Google search.
They look at some APIs.
They go and read up
the documentation.
If that doesn't appeal
to them and they
can't make sense of
the documentation
and then the usage of
that API fast enough,
they're going to move
to something else.
That's one way to do it.
The other one is they're
going to look at the community
wherever they are, whether
they are hanging around
in Stack Overflow, or they
go to an event like this,
they're going to talk to people.
And guess what?
They're going to ask them, hey,
what payment API you guys use
in your e-commerce site?
Somebody's going
to say, I use this.
Why?
It's easy to use.
It took me 10 minutes
to integrate that
into my workflow, or
one day and we're done.
That is what the
developer is looking for.
Now, when you produce an API
for whatever the business
you are in, you're going to
have the same level of scrutiny,
no matter what.
Now, it may not be half
an hour, it may not
be a 10-minute
benchmark, because you
may be in a much more
complex business.
But the speed at which the
developers are consuming
your API is important.
And for you to get there and
improve their experience,
you're going to learn
fine-tune your API,
improve your API constantly.
And if you're not learning
and improving your API,
you're going to lose
the developer who's
going to consume your API,
so hence the need for you
to have the speed at which you
can learn and improve your API.
So it is not about blind speed.
It is not about you
trying to race somebody.
It is just the fact that as you
learn, as you improve your API,
you're going to have a
much better experience
for the developer who's
going to consume it.
And that's the reason why you
want speed in your development
cycle.
So that's why I keep going
back to developer productivity
on both sides, your own
developers and the developers
who are going to consume it--
and the reusability.
So with that context,
what I'm going to do
is invite Prithpal
up on stage, who's
going to actually
walk you through,
very specifically, what
we do in the product
to help facilitate all
these three things,
in terms of security, in terms
of visibility, and in terms
of reusability and enforcement.
Please welcome Prithpal.
[APPLAUSE]
PRITHPAL BHOGILL:
Thank you, Bala.
All right, so Bala's been
touching on a few key things.
And I'm going to just try and
take it to the next level.
So we've been talking
about the data value chain.
We spoke about
the API lifecycle.
And he also touched on
something very important,
which is the API contract.
That's kind of the
common place, where
API providers or the
producing team of APIs
communicate the intent
of what they want to do.
And on the other side
of it, the consumers
of the API, AKA developers
who are building apps,
can understand a
common language.
So I'm going to cover
three key themes.
And we'll actually get
into a live demo mode.
So you'll see me talking
about some concepts,
lay some groundwork,
get into our demo.
And so I'm going to
cover consistency first.
Then we'll talk
about reusability.
And lastly, we'll go address
the enforcement pieces.
So let's talk a little
bit about consistency.
I think, to me, one of the
key things which comes up
in my conversations with
customers is we just want
a common language,
a common vocabulary,
where the API provider
team-- that is,
the team who's building APIs--
can do it in a very
consistent way,
so that the consumer side of
it, which is the app developers,
can consume that in a way
that makes sense to them,
and more importantly,
adopt those APIs.
Bala also mentioned
the word OpenAPI.
So OpenAPI is one of
those common standards
which have really taken a lot
of traction in the industry.
It used to be previously
known as Swagger.
So many of our
customers today, when
they start to think about
what an API should be,
they lever the OpenAPI
Spec to do that.
And there are a dozen tools
available out there for you
to author through OpenAPI Specs.
But one of the key advantages
of the OpenAPI Spec in general
is the ability for it
to be language-agnostic.
So that's one way for you to
describe the intent of what
your API is, what
kind of operations
are going to be
supported on the API,
and more importantly, what
kind of capabilities of the API
that are going to be supported.
It's very easy to understand.
There's huge adoption.
As Bala also
mentioned, not only are
we supporting OpenAPI
for some time,
we are a very active
contributing member
of that specification.
So you'll continue to see that.
In this segment here,
I'm going to show you
a little bit about the
Apigee Edge product
and specific pieces of
how, for the API provider,
you can use the integrated
OpenAPI editor to collaborate
and build APIs.
Let's switch over
to the demo, please.
Excellent.
So what you see
out here right now
is the Apigee Edge
user interface.
In fact, this is the new
Apigee Edge experience.
And this is something
which we have released
in the last few months.
One of the key themes
of this user experience
is making it very intuitive
for the API provider.
So in this case, I happen to
be logged into Apigee Edge.
Apigee, as you know from
a product perspective,
is available in the cloud
and also on premises.
I'm logged onto
the cloud product.
On the top left,
you can see the org,
which is organization for short,
which is available out here.
And that's the one
that I'm connected to.
Now, what I'm
going to do is just
play along with the
theme of consistency.
And we'll take a look at how it
makes it super easy for an API
provider to build consistent API
proxies using an OpenAPI Spec.
So I'm just going
to hover over here.
So this is an example of a
very simple OpenAPI Spec.
This is the starting
point of how
someone starts to describe
what an API should be.
So I'm just going to
use this as a source.
So I'm logged into
my Apigee instance.
One of the very first
things that I want to do
is click on the Specs icon.
And what this does
is it brings me
to a screen where I
as an API provider
can now start putting some very
initial pieces into the story
out here.
So let's say I'm going
to call this a commerce
folder because I want to build
a very simple products API.
So note, I just kind of created
a very simple folder here.
Let's go into it.
And let's go build a new spec.
So I can just go
out here and start
creating a very simple
spec, in which case
you can see it has an
integrated OpenAPI editor.
I can start making
changes out here.
And as I'm making
changes, you can
see some live updates happening
on the right-hand side.
So this is the genesis of
a very, very simple API.
Take it a step forward and
try and build something
a little bit more elaborate.
Let's go, actually, import
an existing API Spec.
So we'll call this
thing the product API.
And I had just shown a
URL a few minutes back.
Let's go ahead and
click on Import.
Within a couple
of clicks, I'm now
able to actually pull
together the entire API spec.
And this API spec,
as you can imagine,
would have been built out
by different API developers.
You could have one team
who could have started
doing this thing all
year, then passed it along
to another team.
In this case, once you import
this API spec into Apigee Edge,
there is an asset repository
which will store all the API
specs in there.
So you think about
collaboration,
once you have
imported an API spec
and you want to now
collaborate on this
with rest of your developer
teams, you can easily do that.
You can see one of the key
elements of this editor
is to ensure that you have some
clean API documentation which
many customers are accustomed
to using gets surfaced.
So in this case,
it's pretty clear
that the intent is to be able
to get a specific product out
of the product collection.
This is one of the key things
which Bala had touched on.
This is very important.
If your APIs are not
easy, if they aren't
consistent and simple to use,
chances are, your developers
are going to move to another
one very, very quickly.
I'll give a very simple analogy.
If you were to flip
out your cell phone
and take a look at an
app, and if the app takes
more than three or
four seconds to load,
that describes the
user experience.
And I can guarantee,
many folks are
going to be searching at the
App Store for a newer app.
Believe it or not, a
very similar experience
is happening in
the industry today.
Bala spoke about some
payment providers.
Pay Easy, Stripe-- they are
dime a dozen payment providers.
If you do not cut
the friction and make
your API simple and easy
to use, the app developers
are going to another
provider very, very quickly.
This is very important.
So you can see, given
the tools and making
all those capabilities
available within the product,
it makes it very simple
for the API developer
to start working with this.
It doesn't really end here.
The key proposition from
here and the future which
is core to Apigee is, great,
I now have an API spec,
how do I take it from the design
phase to the develop phase?
Just using that button, I'm able
to actually click and generate
an API proxy.
An API proxy is nothing
but-- think of that
as a message flow,
where you can add
a bunch of different policies.
So you may have some
APIs on the backend,
which is mentioned out here.
You see the existing API URL?
That is nothing but
the existing API.
That's a backend API.
It could be a product API.
It could be an order API.
Using this tooling,
I'm able to create
an API proxy in
which you can add
certain interesting policies.
So let's say you have an older
API, but it's not secure.
I can create an API proxy,
which becomes like a facade.
Think of that as a facade.
And I can just add
a security policy.
And just by using configuration
or indirect constructs,
and guess what happens,
your API suddenly
is now secure using OAuth.
I can also add things such
as transformation, et cetera.
So you get the point.
You may have one, or
two, or three APIs
that you explored on this
side to your consumers,
but you can manage all
the inconsistencies
that you may have today by
using some clean consistent
standards.
So I can take this
a step forward.
Click on Next.
Next, add certain
choices here, deploy it.
And at this point in time,
in less than three minutes,
I've taken an API spec and
generated an API proxy.
This proxy is deployed
in the testing room.
And I can try it, I can use it.
Think about the lifecycle
and how collaboration
could be achieved using some of
the tools that Apigee provides.
So let's switch back
to the slides please.
So let's talk a little
bit about reusability
because this is a very,
very important aspect.
And one of the key things
which Bala touched on early on
is, it's not only just a few
ad hoc API developers building
APIs, although many
start that way.
We see we have big
enterprise customers who
have hundreds of API developers
across different business
organizations and
different teams.
When you're talking
about doing things
at scale, every single action,
every single configuration
counts.
We have customers who have
well over hundreds of thousands
of APIs in some instances.
Some have internal APIs.
Some have external
APIs, which are
exposed to the outside world.
So where does
reusability kick in?
Some of the common things
we see our customers do
is, I may have a
very specific way
of solving a specific utility
function within the enterprise.
Using Apigee Edge,
you can create that
as a policy which can be reused
across the entire enterprise.
It saves every API
developer that valuable time
in trying to do
what they need to.
One of the areas that
I'm going to touch on
in this demo segment is a
feature called shared flows.
So shared flows is something
which we have released
in the last 40 days or so.
It gives the ability
for API developers
to be able to share some useful
interaction or design patterns
that they have already sold.
They can be reused across many
other developers for building
APIs.
So in this example, I'm
going to, in the backdrop,
talk about we have many
customers who are integrating.
And I'm sure many
of you guys out here
have very similar needs.
Let's say there's an example
of someone trying to integrate
with Salesforce APIs.
It could be any other
cloud API provider,
for that matter of fact.
There are some very
simple, yet important steps
that you have to do to get
access to the sales force APIs.
And those three things are--
you need to have a user
ID, an account out there.
You need to call
a token endpoint
to get some OAuth token.
And once you have that,
then you can make a call
to the account API, the
case, the opportunity,
so on and so forth.
Think about, for a
second, that you and some
of the other developers are
tasked with building out
some integration internally with
some of those sales force APIs.
There's a very common
pattern that you
have to use across
all the interactions.
So let's take a look at how,
using the shared flow feature,
you can provide those kinds
of mechanics of reusability
within the enterprise.
Let's go to the demo, please.
All right, so short of using
the sales for the APIs,
in this case I'm actually
going to use the API from one
of the Apigee components
called the API BaaS, or Backend
as a Service.
API BaaS is a component
of the Apigee Stack
which gives you the ability
to have data collection.
So you can very quickly, on the
fly, create a data collection.
So you can say, here is an
employee data collection.
I can add some records to it.
It is native JSON-based.
And without doing anything, you
have an API endpoint to that--
so very useful for if you want
to rapidly just prioritize
something.
In some cases,
customers are using
this to support their catalogs.
In some cases, preferences,
so on and so forth.
So I'm going to use that
as a backdrop for this API.
As I mentioned, it
exposes an API endpoint.
So let's take a look at--
just keep your watch out
on this URL out here.
I'll expand this a little bit.
So that's the stage.
So you can see the URL
endpoint on the top right.
Now, this endpoint
and the employees
collection that you can see--
I'm from the LA area, so you
can see a slight Hollywood
preference that I have out
here with the employees
in my employees collection.
So what I'm going to do
out here is, let's quickly
try to call this the
employees collection.
You can see it's
an API endpoint.
So again, I'm just
picking up this
as the backdrop for my example.
This could be the sales for
the API, and any other cloud
provider API, for
that matter of fact.
So when I call this,
you can see that this
is sitting in an area which
doesn't have access super easy.
You need to be able to have
some credentials to get access
to it.
If I was to try the
sandbox version of it--
which is exactly the same
except it's in sandbox--
you can see that I'm getting
the data collection back
from there.
Fair enough?
So the sandbox area
gives me access to that.
It's just free, really, access.
I can just call
the API many times.
But the staging area is
actually a hot environment,
and you want to be able to
have the right credentials.
So let's take a
quick peek at how
you could go about using the
tooling to build API proxies
and reuse some of
those policies.
So let me go back to
the API Proxy tab.
And the API Proxy tab is there.
As you would expect, you can see
different kinds of API proxies
you've built. So I'm going
to bring up the Employees API
proxy.
This is something which I
whipped up very quickly.
You can see that I have some old
view information on the screen
out here.
It can tell you
where it is deployed.
It shows you the same
backend URL, which I just
created for you guys live.
So this API proxy is
now actually going
to make a call to this
backend that I just called.
And you can add a lot of
different kinds of policies
to make the API magic work.
So I want a shorten
revision of this API.
And what I'm going
to do out here
is, I'll click on
the Develop tab.
And I'll show your
Revision 1 here.
So I'll call out certain things.
What you're really
seeing out here
is the anatomy of an API proxy.
This is how an API
proxy looks like.
So I happen to be in the
API Proxy Editor View.
And in this case, you can
see that I have some caching
policies which I've used.
We actually happen to have 30
out-of-the-box policies to do
a variety of different
kinds of things.
So you can do
traffic management.
You can do security, which
I'll cover in the next piece.
You can do threat protection.
You can do mediation.
And more importantly,
the platform
is extensible, which means you
can alter your own policies.
So in this case, in the
Employees API proxy,
I had three things
that I'm doing.
I have to make a call to a
token endpoint on my API BaaS
instance, passing in
certain credentials.
Once I get that, it is going to
return to me an access token.
So I make a call with
some credentials,
I get an access
token, because we
are trying to access the
stage environment, which
requires some
authorization before I
can access any dataset.
And then, that header
needs to be set.
So just imagine
this for a second,
these three activities
have to be done,
no matter whether I'm trying
to access the employees
collection, or an
activities collection,
or a hotels dataset,
or whatever dataset
that you've created out there.
So in this case, we go to this
thing called a shared flow.
So in the shared
flow, in this area,
you can go create shared flow.
Then shared flows are nothing
but a very simple construct.
Think of that as an API
proxy at some level,
but it's kind of
a flow which can
contain policies which can
be referenced by multiple API
proxies.
So just play along with
me for a few seconds.
It'll become very clear.
So in this case,
I know that I need
to access those three
policies we just discussed--
make a call to API BaaS token
endpoint, get the old token
and set it in the
header, whether I'm
trying to call the
employees collection
or any other collection.
So let's go into
the shared flow.
And in this shared flow, if
I click on the Develop tab,
you can see that I've
copied the exact same three
policies in here.
I just showed you Revision
1 of the API proxy.
And I'm just saying,
all right, let me now
move them into a shared
flow, because I know,
once I'm solving this for
my employees API proxy,
this functionality is going
to be needed by developers
across many other
backend collections,
and we can solve this
once and reuse that
across many implementations.
So I have a shared
flow, and it's
deployed both to the test
and the product environment.
I'm going back to
the API proxies.
I now have the
employees API proxy.
And I'll switch to Revision
3, which is out here.
And in the Develop
tab now, you can
see that I accessed
that using something
called as a flow callout.
So in this case,
all I have done is
I've shown you the shared flow
with those three policies.
And in this case, I'm just
making a call to that.
So think about all the
other developers who
are going to be now needing
access to either the employees
collection or any of
the data collection
that you build out there, can
just reuse the exact same flow
across all the APIs.
Let's try and test this thing.
One of the interesting
things that I'm
sure you're going to see this
thing in some other sessions
as well, is the ability
to look at what's
going on when an API
proxy is being tested out.
It's very useful for some
customers and developers who
are actually building APIs and
want to be able to quickly test
out some of these things.
You come and put the API
proxy in a trace mode.
And now, I'm going to
call not this endpoint,
but the employees endpoint out.
Here this is a new
API endpoint which
is enabled by the API proxy.
So let's call this.
And you can see that I get the
data back from the collection.
So we did a few things.
I showed you what
a shared flow is.
kind of policies
you can attach out there.
And then I also showed
how that shared flow
can be invoked from one
or multiple API proxies.
So that's a great
way for you to be
able to distribute some
of the common things
that you're doing across some
backend third party systems,
and then leverage that in
your development initiatives.
Awesome.
So now, let's take
it to the next level.
Can we switch to
the slides, please?
So Bala spoke about
one very key thing.
As you start to scale
out your API program,
as you have not one,
10, but hundreds,
and more and more
APIs, it becomes
very important to
have some very, very
horizontal cross-cutting
policies enforced.
So what do I mean by that?
It's very important to
leverage your API platform
to be agile so you can really
roll out APIs very rapidly.
That's important.
That's what an API developer or
an API provider is tasked with.
They just want to roll
out APIs very quickly.
However, from a security and
a compliance perspective,
those teams want
to ensure that when
APIs make it into
production, they are secure.
They cannot afford to delegate
the responsibility and assume
and trust that the developers
are going to do that.
With all good
intentions, developers
will try and do
what they need to,
but there are
common requirements
such as I need to have
consistent security across all
my APIs.
That's something that the
security and the compliance
team needs to have the ability
at their level to enforce it.
The other thing is logging.
Let's say there's a requirement
from an audit perspective.
And many of our customers do--
in fact, many of my customers
that we talk to say, because
APIs are the face to the world
digitally, and they are now
enabling many interactions
through APIs, that means
every single interaction which
happens on that channel has to
be recorded, has to be audited,
has to be logged somewhere.
And many of our customers
use several different kinds
of enterprise logging
systems such as Splunk, Sumo,
Loggly, and a few others.
So those aspects
become a very key part
of ensuring that
you have consistency
in terms of security,
consistency in terms
of logging and auditing.
And in this section, I'm going
to show you one feature called
the flow hooks.
It's a great mechanism
for all the administrators
and the security
and compliance folks
who are leveraging
the Apigee platform
to be able to enforce
that using a few clicks.
So we'll talk about
how flow hooks work
and how you can use that feature
to provide the same benefits
in your enterprise as well.
Can you switch to
the demo, please?
So we're back out here.
Now, let's play this thing
a little bit forward.
So you saw a very simple
employees API proxy
which gives me access
to some backend data.
I can do some caching.
And I'm off building
an app on top of it.
Although this is
OK for me to have
an API like this
in development, you
can see that there is no API
key, no API security that
was needed to call this API.
So if I'm a developer
and this is a public URL,
you could try it right now.
You can keep hitting
this endpoint,
and it will give
you the API data.
And although that's OK when
you're developing and testing
it, it's not OK when
you go to production.
The security team has
the responsibility there.
So they want to
ensure that if it
goes into production,
at a minimum that API
is protected using an API key.
Sure, they can have more
exaggerated requirements,
where it needs to have
an OAuth protection.
I need to have some threat
protection, some traffic
management.
So let's use the simple example
of let's try and protect
this API, but the ops
and the security team
want to be very,
very clear of not
delegating the responsibility,
and relying that the developers
are going to do it.
Because we have a
bunch of developers
who are off building
their APIs, but production
is the environment
that they control.
So let's show you how the flow
hook feature kind of enables
that.
So as an example, I have this
API proxy deployed in the fraud
environment as well.
Let's just call this--
I'm going to change the URL
to now say demo5-product.
And let me try to
call this thing.
Right away you can see
that I need an API key.
How did this happen?
It's the exact same API
proxy which the developer
built and has deployed it.
But something changed in
the production environment.
Let's take a peek on
how that happened.
So if I go back to the
Employees API proxy,
I still have those two
things-- caching responses
returning from there if you
can, or make those three policy
calls to access
the backend system.
Here is where the magic starts.
In this Admin tab, when
I click on Environments,
I have a few key things
which show up here.
I'll try and zoom
in a little bit.
The one that I really
want to share out here
is the flow hooks.
So flow hooks is a
very simple mechanism
to say that I have
four entry points.
So think about an API proxy.
As I mentioned, an API proxy
is nothing but a facade.
If you think of this as
your right-hand side,
or my left-hand side, and think
of this as being your employees
backend endpoint or
your third party APIs,
on the right-hand side, or to
your left, is the API consumer.
In the middle is the API proxy.
That's where any call
which comes from here
gets intercepted and gets passed
on to the right-hand side.
So there are four key
touch points out there,
or hooks, if you would.
One is the pre-proxy,
the pre-target,
and the post-target,
and the post-proxy.
In a very simple way,
what that means is,
do some checks on this side
before I even go there.
And do some checks on this
side before we actually
send them to the backend.
So in this case, in
the test environment,
I do not have anything out here.
That's why when I'm making
a call to the employee API
proxy in the test environment,
it works flawlessly
without any API key.
But let's go switch this
to the prod environment.
Once I change the environment
from test to prod--
aha, you can see that there's
a common security shared
flow which had been enabled
at the pre-proxy flow hook.
This is something which the
security and the compliance
team can easily affect.
They can go in out
here and put all kinds
of things, all
kinds of shared flow
for the different elements.
So in this case, we use a
common security shared flow.
Let's go take a look
at what that is.
If I go back to the shared flow,
in the common security shared
flow, which is only deployed
to the prod environment,
and hence, you could see
that the API was protected
by default without the
developer having to do anything
in the prod environment.
And in this case, there
is a verify API key policy
in there, which is expecting
an API key in the request
parameter.
So just by simple
clicks, we were
able to kind of put this
power in the hands of the ops
team, the security and
the compliance teams,
to be able to ensure
that APIs are protected.
And you can expand this thing
to saying, in this shared flow,
or in some other ones
at different levels,
you can actually have
method logging policy.
So method logging policy is an
example of an out-of-the-box
policy which can be used to
log to any enterprise logging
system.
So now, in this case, let's
switch back to the Postman
client that I've been using.
And I'll actually change the
collection that I'm using,
or the endpoint.
I'm going to call
the prod endpoint.
But in this case, I'm going
to actually supply an API key.
So an API key, in
this case, what
generated through Apigee Edge,
in which we say, great, someone
needs the easy
access to the API,
you can go and
generate an API key
which can be shared
with your consumer.
It serves dual purposes.
Not only it provides
a step of security
so that the API can only be
called when an API key gets
passed in, but it also serves
as an excellent identification
mechanism, where
if you're thinking
about a bunch of
partners or consumers
who are calling your
APIs, As you then
have a very great insight into
who is actually the biggest
adopter of the APIs, something
which product managers care
very deeply about.
If you're thinking of running
your business using APIs,
that kind of mechanics
play a very important role
in figuring out who is actually
a big user of the APIs.
So in this case, I'm
going to pass the API key.
And you can see
that in production I
can now start accessing the
APIs as I was in development.
Makes sense?
And if I go back to
trying to call this API
endpoint in production
without an API key,
it will consistently fail.
Test, I can keep calling
it multiple times--
whoops.
Change this to test.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
Great.
So we took a look
at three themes.
We spoke about consistency.
We spoke about how you can
use the OpenAPI Editor to be
able to have collaboration,
have some consistency in how
you define the APIs.
We looked at some
features of the product
in the area of reusability,
which was all about
I'm building up
API to scale, I'm
having some common capabilities
and functionalities
that I want to share
across my enterprise.
The shared flow is a great
mechanism to do that.
And lastly, we spoke
about enforcement.
And you looked at how
we could use flow hooks
to be able to enforce some
very common security, logging,
and compliance
requirements using
configuration-oriented
constructs.
So I'm going to turn it over
back to Bala at this point
to take us to close.
BALA KASIVISWANATHAN:
Thank you, Prithpal.
So hopefully the demo
was very illustrative
of the things we talked about,
in terms of when we think about
security, reusability,
and enforcement,
and how do we achieve
that in the product.
And going back to the
summary view here,
the reason we care
about this deeply is we
want the API platform
to be all about getting
your adoption for your APIs.
If you have great APIs
and nobody's using them,
it's kind of a waste.
So we want to make sure that
all your internal developers
and external developers
are able to take advantage
of those APIs, you're
able to scale and serve
those developers very, very well
and applications really well.
And the last one is,
of course, that you
want to make sure
that you still have
a lot of control and security
mechanisms around those APIs.
All this, to
reinforce the point,
is helping you drive agility,
helping you deliver things
at speed so they can
learn, improve, and iterate
over and over again.
So with that context, to close
out, what you've seen today,
and how it benefits
your API program,
if I have to kind of
summarize that for you,
it is essentially giving
you agility, at scale,
with security.
So if you have one take-away
from the session, it will be,
how do you have a
speed of execution
at scale for a lot of your
APIs with the security needs
that you need to comply with?
[MUSIC PLAYING]